more so than ever the air in Washington
is thick with intrigue and controversy
the public hearings in the latest Trump
impeachment saga are into their second
week and everyone wants to know has he
done it will this be the straw that
finally breaks the camel's back
president used taxpayer dollars to ask
the Ukrainians to help him cheat in
election
that can't be right guys I think we've
got the wrong soundbite in there
what really okay no apparently that is
right hashtag what gate is on everyone's
lips
Democratic Representative Eric's wall
well was weighing in on the ongoing
impeachment hearings when he dropped
dropped an explosive bomb on MSNBC
you'd think though that while one-world
human stuff happens move on and to the
President of the United States of
America could possibly be impeached
potentially just the third in the
country's history but no the scandal
over that inquit moment on air is
refusing really to blow over and
mainstream media is leading the charge
trying to get to the bottom of it I'm
really sorry about this but I have to
ask if this was you or someone in the
studio it was not me and I didn't hear
it when I was speaking you look like you
heard it and are stifling a LOF hi-def
did not hear it even politicians have
jumped on to the bandwagon keen to show
off their sharp wit excuse me may I go
to the bathroom first of course you may
crews made a rookie error and forgot
that he too had been involved in a story
that also rippled far and wide to shea
senator and thank you for keeping it
clean you know without tweeting out more
porn so let's see what all the
conspiracy theories on the table are the
program on which it happened hardball
tried to cover up its tracks and said it
was just the presenters scraping his mug
across the table to which swore well
took a leaf out of Trump's book and
breathed a sigh of relief but let's test
that one out Neal over to you hmm
not sure so maybe another one the
cameraman was to blame they always think
they're safe just because they're
lurking in the shadows but guys is that
even possible
no neither of the fairies held up to
scrutiny though viewers smelt a rat
Pluto was demoted as a planet but Erik's
whoa whoa and it's now secure among the
gas giants Eric's wall wall is not again
data that you can stand behind the
cover-up is always worse than a crime so
while Iran faces protests Bolivia faces
a coup Trump faces possible impeachment
and the UK faces yet another string of
brexit delays the media follows its very
funny
excellent nose for stories let's see
when this one runs out of gas okay
that's it this is ridiculous I mean I
don't know who can talk about this
seriously I'm done
you